então eu estava lá como aluno nos
primeiros anos do ensino fundamental e
sentado na minha cadeira na minha
carteira dentre tantas carteiras
enfileirados naquela lógica de produção
massiva e industrial do conhecimento é
de imposição massiva industrial do
conhecimento em que eu estava ali na
minha carteira o professor lá na frente
todos aqueles alunos em federados e
então eu desenvolvi uma atividade que
foi passada pela professora é uma
professora pela qual eu tenho muito
carinho até hoje né e era uma atividade
de redação e um determinado momento
quando escrevi a minha redação eu parei
numa palavra que eu não sabia como
escrever e era a palavra amarrou do
verbo amarrar
então eu me levantei da minha carteira
fui até a professora e perguntei
professora como se escreve amarrou é o
professor olhou pra mim e disse não é a
marrom é marrom e eu então voltei até a
minha carteira e não conseguia
desenvolver a redação porque me faltava
como escrever aquela palavra então eu me
levantei novamente fui até a professora
e perguntei professora como se escreve
amarrou ea professora disse eu já te
falei não é a marrom se levantou
escreveu no quadro marrom
então o que eu fiz eu voltei e me sentei
na minha carteira e não terminei a minha
redação
a questão é não é o fato de a professora
ela ter se equivocado realmente ela se
equivocou não ouviu exatamente o que eu
perguntei uma pessoa pela qual tenho
muito carinho a questão é porque eu como
estudante uma criança naquele momento eu
não consegui me colocar para a
professora eu não consegui dizer pela
professora a senhora errou não é isso
que estou perguntando e a resposta para
essa pergunta ela passa por nós
compreendermos a estrutura social de
convivência que nós estamos inseridos
estrutura social de convivência que nós
estamos inseridos ela está baseada ela
foi construída em
uma lógica cartesiana mecanicista que
foi desenvolvida entre 1500 e 1700 há
séculos atrás uma estrutura que está
pautada que está assentada nas
diretrizes do individualismo do
utilitarismo do consumismo e da exclusão
uma estrutura social que implica a ordem
da hierarquia a dominação de um sobre os
outros
uma estrutura social que implica a
lógica da competição ea competição é a
base da guerra
não é à toa que as pessoas hoje se
odeiam não é à toa que as pessoas hoje
não se vêem como opositores quando
pensam de forma diferente opositores com
quem se dialoga mas se vem como inimigos
inimigos que devem ser aniquilados
porque na base de tudo isso está a
competição uma estrutura de convivência
social que impõe violências
há muitas e muitas pessoas violências
não só físicas e psíquicas essas também
mas acima de tudo violências estruturais
que significam privar pessoas do acesso
a serviços e recursos que em tese
deveriam estar disponíveis a todos e
também violências culturais que
significam privar pessoas ou impor
outras formas de violência pessoas por
conta da sua origem social por conta da
sua origem territorial por conta da sua
raça
por conta da sua condição de gênero ou
por conta da sua opção sexual
e esta lógica da estrutura da
convivência social ela está também nas
nossas instituições
as nossas instituições assim como a
escola e tantas outras instituições até
mesmo o sistema de justiça elas estão
pautadas por essa mesma lógica a lógica
hierárquica a lógica punitiva a lógica
excludente
as escolas ainda acreditam que a base da
convivência está na imposição que a base
da convivência está no controle pelo
medo
tanto assim que existe uma pesquisa das
em cena de terror ou da agência anti
terror norte americana na qual se buscou
entender por que os alunos ou alguns
alunos em um determinado momento eles
pegam armas que ingressam nas escolas e
atiram nos colegas ea conclusão a que
essa pesquisa chegou é que o que motiva
os alunos a terem esse comportamento
violento
sam é o sentimento de não pertencimento
são movimentos que fazem com que esses
alunos se sintam excluídos como por
exemplo o bullying como por exemplo
punições como por exemplo formas de não
reconhecimento e de não protagonismo ou
seja as nossas instituições como as
escolas elas não geram pertencimento não
geram o sentimento de pertencimento às
pessoas que nela convivem não só para
alunos mas também para professores
também para a direção porque a estrutura
da instituição ela é sufocante para
todas as pessoas
neste momento existe uma transformação
na concepção filosófica do mundo
nós estamos deixando para trás essa
lógica cartesiana mecanicista para
entrarmos em uma outra lógica numa
lógica holística de maneira que os
organismos vivos como a natureza eles
são enxergados como um conjunto de
relações não mais como uma coleção de
partes e o foco hoje está na relação às
relações de maneira que o ser humano ele
é apenas uma teia em um feixe de teias
em um feixe de relações e é nessa ordem
de ideias que chega a justiça
restaurativa
a justiça restaurativa é muito mais do
que uma técnica de resolução de
conflitos apesar de ter um rol de
técnicas de resolução de conflitos mas a
justiça restaurativa é um convite para a
mudança dos paradigmas de convivência
social é uma um convite para que a
sociedade repense essa lógica de
competição de dominação para passarmos a
construir uma lógica de compreensão de
atendimento de necessidades de
construção de responsabilidades
individuais e coletivas ou seja para
construirmos uma lógica de cooperação
a justiça restaurativa é um grande
anfitrião que reúne todas as pessoas da
comunidade para que todas juntas elas
possam pensar a partir das suas
diferentes visões de mundo em caminhos
que sejam bons pra todos e não exclui
ninguém e quando nós falamos em justiça
restaurativa
nós não estamos falando no sistema de
justiça no poder judiciário não a
palavra justiça da justiça restaurativa
diz respeito ao valor justiça ao valor
justo e nós entendemos então que a
justiça restaurativa e se fazer justiça
ele deve ser construído pela comunidade
com a comunidade e para a comunidade de
maneira que o judiciário ele é apenas um
mais um integrante desse coletivo
comunitário no qual a justiça
restaurativa ela é construída e quando a
proposta da justiça restaurativa é
implementada seja em unidades
comunitárias ou em escolas ou em outras
ambiência cela traz sim é uma técnica de
resolução de conflitos e como eu disse
ela tem um rol de técnicas de resolução
de conflitos ea mais conhecida delas é o
processo circular e aqui eu trago um
exemplo do processo circular
desenvolvido no ambiente escolar em uma
determinada situação não chegou em um
processo até o sistema de justiça há o
caso de um aluno que quebrou o braço de
uma aluna
e assim chegou a situação no sistema de
justiça o aluno ele era o agressor ea
menina era a vítima e esse caso ele foi
derivado para o trabalho na justiça
restaurativa
de maneira que o processo ele foi
paralisado bem quando se trabalhou nessa
situação do processo circular em que
estavam presentes ali dois facilitadores
que são pessoas devidamente capacitados
para esse trabalho e também o menino com
seus familiares a menina com seus
familiares
comunidade escolar que foi direta e
indiretamente atingida e também a rede
de garantia de direitos o que se
entendeu é que há quatro anos
esse menino vinha sofrendo bullying por
parte dessa menina
então um dia né esse menino a 1 cujo pai
estava desempregado é começou a fazer
uso de álcool e chegava em casa e batia
no menino esse menino que sofria toda
essa carga de violência chegou até a
escola e mais uma vez ele sofreu
bullying por parte dessa menina que o
chamava de gordo baleia quatro olhos
como ela fazia há quatro anos
então esse menino ele empurrou a garota
a garota caiu e quebrou o braço
é durante o trabalho do processo
circular restaurativo é esse garoto ele
entendeu que apesar de tudo ele não
tinha o direito de ter quebrado o braço
daquela menina então ele se comprometeu
junto com a família dele a reparar os
danos materiais que aquela menina teve a
menina também entendeu como fui à sua
responsabilidade por tudo aquilo que
aconteceu ea família dela também se
comprometeu a orientar melhor a filha no
que diz respeito ao respeito com relação
aos colegas
bom pra além disso né ou a comunidade e
também a rede de garantia de direitos se
comprometeu a ajudar aquele pai a se
recolocar no mercado de trabalho ea
lidar com o problema do alcoolismo e da
violência dentro de casa ea escola
também entendeu a sua
corresponsabilidade por nunca ter
trabalhado a questão da violência dentro
do ambiente escolar
então aqueles alunos juntamente com a
escola se comprometeram a desenvolver um
trabalho anti bullying e anti violência
dentro da escola bem mas a justiça
restaurativa ela não se basta nessa
técnica de resolução de conflitos quando
ela chega em uma instituição ela propõe
para esta instituição que a instituição
reveja a sua estrutura de convivência
interna de maneira que a instituição
como a escola ela desenvolva uma gestão
mais democrática ela desenvolva projetos
que garantam
o vencimento que garantam vez e voz a
todos que permitam aos alunos aos
professores e até mesmo a direção a
serem protagonistas que todos se sintam
pertencentes àquele espaço ou seja que
todos passem a se responsabilizar ea se
corresponsabilizar por pensar e resolver
os problemas daquele ambiente
então a justiça restaurativa chega assim
uma técnica de resolução de conflitos
dialógica inclusiva que olha para a
reparação dos danos que olha para o
atendimento das necessidades que olha
para a construção das responsabilidades
individuais porque quem causa dano a
outrem têm responsabilidade
responsabilidade no sentido de reparar
os danos não só para a pessoa que sofreu
dano mas pra pessoa também é mais para a
comunidade também que foi atingida por
aquele fato e também responsabilidade
por reconstruir a sua trajetória de vida
mas ao mesmo tempo existe a co
responsabilidade coletiva porque essa
pessoa que fez ela não fez sozinha
existiram falhas existiram omissões na
vida dessa pessoa por parte da família
da comunidade do poder público que
contribuíram para que essa pessoa
chegasse onde ela chegou e por outro
lado a justiça restaurativa também atua
nessa dimensão institucional lepra que a
própria instituição ela reveja a sua
forma de convivência interna para que a
técnica ela não seja copiada para a
manutenção das estruturas de poder mas
que há a técnica ela sirva então para a
transformação das estruturas de poder
junto com esse trabalho macro
institucional é de um convite para que
todos ali repensem nas suas formas de
convivência interna e para além disso a
justiça restaurativa também atua em uma
lógica social espraiando os valores e os
princípios da justiça restaurativa por
toda a sociedade principalmente por meio
da criação de grupos gestores
interinstitucionais que reúnem
representantes de todos os setores
sociais tanto públicos quanto privados e
também da sociedade civil organizada
para que todos em raiz
a justiça restaurativa como política
pública
e já que estamos falando então de
justiça restaurativa e mudanças de
paradigma eu trago aqui na mais uma
historinha né e uma história da minha
vida recente e em determinado momento eu
tenho uma filhinha de quatro anos de
idade e rafaela ea minha filha ela gosta
de assistir desenhos como toda criança e
como vocês sabem né as crianças quando
elas assistem desenhos ela não assistem
desenhos elas assistem um desenho um
milhão de vezes que a minha filha em um
determinado momento ela em casa ela
encasquetou com desenho monstros s/a e
ali quando nós estávamos já na 50ª vez
assistindo monstros s/a
eu comecei a buscar entender qual era a
mensagem que estava por trás daquele
desenho longa metragem
e aí eu entendi que existe uma proposta
de transformação de paradigmas muito
interessante ali né vocês eu acredito
que muitos aqui já assistiram na iemg
conhecem a história mas ali no desenho
monstros s/a
não existe a sociedade demonstrou polis
a sua a cidade dos monstros de
monstrópolis ea cidade precisa de uma
energia vital para sobreviver como mais
ou menos a nossa energia elétrica mas
algo para além disso uma energia vital
que é produzida por meio de indústrias
ea principal dessas indústrias era a
monstros s/a e ali dentro da indústria
existe um time de monstros de elite que
eles entram no quarto das crianças
humanas por meio de uma porta
dimensional que os leva até o guarda
roupa das crianças enquanto elas dormem
eles assustam a criança ea criança grita
e com o grito dessa criança ele gera
energia e essa energia do grito ela é
armazenada e se você como vocês podem
perceber né pra os monstros gerar então
energia para monstrópolis eles precisam
causa dor para as crianças sofrimento
violência e qual é o discurso que foi
criado para que os monstros eles não têm
empatia com a criança para que eles
possam causar dor sem o menor
constrangimento
as crianças são tóxicas elas podem
destruir o mundo demonstrou polis
seja ou viram esse discurso alguma vez
no nosso mundo por exemplo negros não
têm alma nós podemos escravizá los
usá-los para servir os interesses vitais
da nossa sociedade
judeus são como animais nós podemos matá
los porque eles atentam contra a nossa
sociedade e agora as novas formas nem
que se defende que determinados grupos
de pessoas que fazem alguma coisa tem
que morrer pra manter a sociedade viva
sobre o que aconteceu e monstrópolis foi
o seguinte por um acidente uma criança
ela fez o caminho contrário e entrou e
mostrou polis e naquele momento os
monstros que são os personagens
principais eles se afeiçoaram a criança
entenderam que a criança ela não era
tóxico ela não causava mau e entenderam
algo maior ainda eles entenderam que o
sorriso da criança alegria da criança
girava dez vezes mais energia para a
sobrevivência de monstrópolis do que o
grito do que a dor
será que um dia nós como sociedade vamos
entender isso que não é com dor não é
com sofrimento não é um ódio que nós
vamos criar energia vital para a
sobrevivência da nossa sociedade mas sim
com alegria mas sim com a união mas sim
com conexão humana e principalmente com
amor e essa é a proposta da justiça
restaurativa justiça restaurativa que
antes de pretender transformar o outro
nos convida a nos transformarmos muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]